[Music]
thank you for scheming your siesta today
I think it's good that we can stop sorry
okay so I'll be talking about some joint
work with Eddie that's here and Marc
Schreuder that was a postdoc in Chile
thanassis that was a post up with Eddie
at UT Austin they all visit Chile we met
for some time and we started working on
this and we've been working on this for
almost a year so so what's the situation
so what we want to understand a little
bit better is what happens when you have
a network in which links are operated by
say private companies so in the setting
we have some network owners so every say
every owner has its own link
and they can set at all on that link and
they want to maximize profit on the
other hand so at the second level we
have travelers that actually pick their
best possible choice so shortest path
including the time it takes to traverse
and at all and we are in a situation in
which there is congestion so we are
again in the congestion game setting so
the more travelers you have on a link
they hired the Casa DS and that all is
just fixed so it's a per travel toll so
what's tricky here is that equilibrium
on the so the game on the on the player
sides is on the drivers science if you
want this is what understood we know a
lot about this game it's been studied in
the transportation science literature
since 50s but what's tricky is that if
you are this network of I mean these
network operators then we lose many of
the nine
properties of the game in particular we
may have that the game does not have an
equilibrium we may have that either the
best responses are just to set higher
and higher tolls we may also have that
this does not happen but they know
equilibria I mean in pure strategies
okay so it may also happen that this
cycle so the toes don't grow forever but
they start cycle and I'll show you an
example what this happens I believe I
may not be unique and apollomon will be
a bitterly inefficient so what we try to
do is to add some regulation in the game
and what we'll do is to add cups on the
maximum tall and linked operator can
charge and we see that this solution
actually resolves all three all three
issues that we have there I mean to some
extent so as a motivating example
consider the you probably don't know it
but this is something oh and this is the
highways the privately operated highways
in Santiago which have been there since
the 90s or there have been constructing
different urban highways and there are
several companies that operate these
highways they have to construct them and
then they have to do some maintenance on
them and they can charge tolls and these
tolls are set every a year or two years
and they're set of cups so really these
are cups so the companies can actually
lower their tolls if they want and by
lowering the toll you attract more flow
so it's not completely ridiculous to
lower the toll and an empirical
observation is that this basically does
not happen so it only happens on some
weekends that companies actually lower
the dose but if you look at weekdays
like heavy traffic conditions they never
lower the dots and one question is why
and there are several explanations so I
guess the most common explanation is to
say that you know what these guys own I
mean this this highway here actually has
some flow that's that's capture I mean
it's important
that someone traveling for I mean in in
a different part of the city will use
this highway and some people that use
this I mean that live around this
highway and work around this highway
will always take it and that's one
reason to say ok they will never lower
the tone but we provide another
explanation for this as and I will go
into this ok so this is the setting we
have some network which is a graph we
have origins and destinations and we
have some demand for every part for
every St siit I pear and every link has
suffered some congestion so we say that
the cost of choosing some path is just
the sum of the cost of the edges in the
path this this course will depend on the
amount of flow on that link so every
link suffer some congestion if more
people is using a link the higher the
cost the cost of a path is just the sum
of this cost along a path ok so this is
the basic model so what are the the
objectives we want to understand so the
social cost on a of a given flow so if I
give you a flow pattern you can compute
its social cost and its social cost is
going to be just the sum of everybody's
cost so travel cost I mean here just
travel cost and then an optimal flow
it's a it's a flow pattern that actually
minimizes this overall cost so I sum
over all the edges the cost of the edge
which is the flow on the edge times the
cost the congestion on that link right
and then I sum over all these things and
if I minimize this function I I have
what I call a social object ok socially
optimal solution an optimal flow ok so
an equilibrium flow is a different it's
a different object an equilibrium flow
is a situation in which no one wants to
unilaterally deviate right no one no one
can improve its time by just deviating
from his path it's known again since the
50s that such a flow actually has a
variational character
and and if you minimize this cost
function you obtain it I mean it's not
terribly important what this cost
function is but if you minimize this
cost function which is a different cost
function which is also an I mean if this
else are increasing this is the integral
so this is convex and it's nicely
behaved if you minimize this cost
function you get an equality Metro okay
so we want an optimal flow but if we let
people behave as they want they will
reach an equilibrium flow and this
equilibrium flow is worse than an
optimal flow in terms of social cost
okay so what if we introduced tolls so
now we want to say the cost in a link is
going to be its congestion cost so
travel travel cost plus some Tori now
its user and that all is say measured in
time units again okay it transformed it
all into time units now each user is
going to minimize the cost of the path
plus the toll on that path and not just
the cost not just the travel cost so
therefore an equilibrium if I set all te
on link II the equilibrium flow the out
I mean the output of this is going to be
the solution of this new problem in
which I have the same objective before
but with the new cost function on every
link and again and all the result says
that says that if you set that all to be
these marginal tolls
so you put the optimal you compute your
optimal flow and you compute these
quantities in every link and you set
that all to be exactly this quantity
then the outcome the equilibrium outcome
is an optimal flow so that's very nice
so we know how to set those in a way to
induce optimal flows and this is very
old
so now there is a problem here because
what happens if these tolls are not
imposed but are set so that link
operators can actually change them link
operators want to maximize their profit
you will not reach to these tools but
you'll reach to something else so they
are their best response to these tools
will be to move it either up or down and
you will get different a different
solution and so the situation will be
say like this which so we have a network
we have different thoughts that people
can I mean operators can charge and now
a Nash equilibrium is a situation in
which not all operational link operator
wants to actually decrease or increase
his own toll and the strong Nash I mean
it's a stronger notion of equilibrium
which there are no group deviations I
will mostly talk about just Nash here
but everything extent to strong Nash
the individual rationality of the
drivers right yeah so you can I mean in
this model basically we have a fixed
demand model but every everything we do
also works with the elastic demand so
let's say you have some value for
traveling and so everything works in
that setting as well yes no because I
don't see that the link operator would
like to lose money right but then yeah
okay but I'm looking at the situation in
which every link operator wants to
maximize profit okay so it could make
sense but it would be a different
setting right so you then set it to zero
I guess in that situation right now when
operator owns one link in my model and
that's that's a very good question
actually yeah it's a very good question
so one link is owned by one operator and
this operator only know owns one link
okay so it's it's a simple in it's a
stylized model in that setting so this
this work has was probably started by a
so this line of work in like a little
more than ten years ago and then ever
has also work on this and like that
there is a lot of work here it's already
known that what I mentioned that
equilibrium does not exist and there are
different variations study of price of
Anarchy price of stability there are
many many interesting results there but
what we are doing now is adding some
more regulation so that's the difference
of our work from from previous research
so just in this example I mean this is
the simplest example we know in which
you have even linear latencies and
equilibrium does not exist and the
reason it does not exist is because it
cycles not because it does grow to
infinity so if you set some tolls in
this case what happens is that the best
response of
player 1 in this case it's actually not
convex so the best response the the toll
sorry the utility he would get as a
function of the toll would be maximized
at two different points and this is not
a convex set and if you start I mean if
you want to look for an equilibrium it
will turn out that there is none so it
will psyche okay so so now equilibrium
you have all some bound and inefficiency
and you have all this bad behavior so
what we'll do is we introduce upper
bounds on the tolls so we'll say you
know you can charge at all but up to
this quantity okay so the main result
that we have is that if you consider a
set of cups t-bar which is below
marginal tolls and that it induces the
optimal flow okay so a set of tolls
induces an optimal flow if if and only
if when I find the equilibrium with
these tolls then I get an optimal flow
okay marginal toes were just one example
of these that I mentioned before but
there are many I mean the set of tolls
that achieve this objective is quite
large in general and now if you take any
of any such set of tolls with the extra
condition that they are below the
marginal tolls then you are sure that
the equilibrium that this is going to be
a strong Nash equilibrium okay so no one
will want to decrease at all in that
situation and and I think I can emanate
the strong Nash equilibrium proof is
quite complicated but I can do the can
to give you a sense of what's going on I
can give you
most of the proof of this Nash
equilibrium the bar is any opt inducing
tall so it's a total vector that induces
an optimal flow and that is below this
marginal tolls
so let me and then this also works with
the last agreement
so with the last thing run you have some
demand model and it the same is true
okay so one thing so let me try to give
you an idea of how do you prove this so
first would prove a first simple lemma
then a bit more complicated lemma and
then we will see that this simple easily
implies the result so the first simple
lemma says the following so let's take
some some tall vector and let's increase
the taller one link that's it that's all
we do we take some tall vector we take a
link and we increase the toil so what I
claim and I guess it sounds obvious but
still needs to be proved is that the
flow on that link will decrease
equilibrium flow on that link will
decrease so less people will be using
this link but the total cost of the link
we increase so the flow on the link will
decrease and the total flow will good so
why is this so the first part so the
fact that the flow decreases comes from
simply that okay so say X of T is the
flow corresponding to toll T so the
equilibria flow corresponding to toll T
so we know this guy minimizes this
objective and therefore if I evaluate
the objective in X of T I get less than
if I would evaluate the objective in X
of T prime so acti prime is the same as
T except that in one link is different
okay it's just bigger the same is true
for T Prime
so XT prime minimizes the objective when
I said when I put t prime here instead
of T and you just take these two
inequalities which are basically the
optimality conditions of of these flows
and when you add them up there is very
little difference and you realize that
this quantity is negative so very simple
the flow then has to decrease if I
increase it very good now for the total
cost you do a similar argument but
instead of looking at the objective at
this Phi of X you look at the
first-order optimality conditions
so you take this convex program you
derive first-order optimality conditions
and they look like this
they look like this you add them up and
when you add them up there is very
little difference since these two
objectives remember that T prime is the
same as T except in one link so for all
links which are different from the link
the linking which is also different you
get this quantity and in the exact and
in link F you get this other quantity
this new difference I mean now this is
overall this is non-negative but this is
actually positive because else are
increasing functions so you get X of T
prime I minus X and then L evaluated on
X of T Prime and L evaluating X this is
an increasing function so that has to be
non-negative
this we just proven that it's negative
therefore this has to be positive so the
overall the overall cost in the link
increases the flow on the link decreases
perfect now the second limits it's a
little less intuitive so you say take
some tall vector and suppose you have a
local Maximizer of the profit for
operator e then this tall
this local Maximizer has to be large
enough it cannot be very small it has to
be larger than the marginal tall
corresponding to the actual flow there
so this X is the flow under T right the
flow will depend on who who is that all
but in under T this is the flow so what
we are saying here is that if something
is a local Maximizer and of course then
a global Maximizer also satisfies this
then it has to be large enough so why is
this well you just impose the condition
that this is a local Maximizer this can
be equal to zero but I only need the non
negativity condition and therefore you
immediately realize that there has to be
least this quantity now that that's an
positive quantity because this X prime
is now by lemma one we take the ratio of
the two differences the cost of the link
and the flow on the link and this has to
be negative you rearrange this
inequality and you take limit when s
converges to T so s is a little larger
than T you take the limit and when you
take the limit you see that this is the
derivative of the cost function and this
is 1 over the derivative of the flow
minus 1 over the derivative of the flow
and then you just combine things
together I don't know why there is a
question mark here ok
so good so now you are what you know is
that this has to be big enough and now
to finish the proof is very simple with
this two lemmas at hand so what you say
is that I use the lower bound of the
previous lemma then I use convexity so
by convexity I need that L is convex
that's one thing I didn't mention and
now I say I need a dis complex if it's
not convex that result is not true
actually
so by convexity this is an increasing
function l prime is an increasing
function and therefore if I replace it
by a lower by a lower flow by a lower
flow so T bar is higher so the flow is
lower I replace it by a lower flow then
I get that this is this is bigger than
this and this is exactly T hot why is
this because this is an optimally this
flow induces sorry this story in this is
an optimal flow and therefore X times L
prime of X is T hot so we conclude that
if someone wants to deviate to a low at
all then I am a Bob T hot but this lower
toll was already below T hot so you
cannot be perfect so but so what's next
then what are you doing expect we have
this this
nice characterization is nicer polygon
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah absolutely
so now okay it's good we we want obtain
using flow so we want socially optimal
flows now we want also that there is an
equilibrium and we have it in the links
operated fine so we can set tolls in
this way but which would be a desirable
equilibrium so what we'd like is to find
the set of tolls that induces the
optimal flow but that is under it is a
gap equilibrium so no one was to deviate
but also among goes disappear which are
many again we want one that minimizes
say the payments or the travel or the
total cost of the users so then we turn
into these into this situation and it
turns out so let me actually do one
example that I had which is a bit easier
to understand so let's say this is my
network okay so a simple network my flow
my cost functions are X X and X 2 & 2 so
constant equals to 2 and delay linear
delays in the other three and let's say
you have one you need a flow if you do
the math here you can realize that the
optimal flow is actually to send 1/3 of
flow in each of these paths of the red
path so I have 3 red paths and I said
1/3 1/3 of unit of flow therefore the
flow here is 2 over 3 so the marginal
told the derivative of X is 1 the mark
the flow is 2/3
so marginal tours are 2/3 1/3 2/3 okay
so the payment is going to be 2/3
squared 1/3 squared plus 2/3 squared the
payment will be 1 okay so this marginal
tours induce this flow that we know
already so I don't need to prove you
that and once you have that this is the
total payment now this is the best set
of tools that you can put which are
below marginal tools so there is nothing
below marginal tours in this example
however the best tools I mean the one
I'd like to find are this
guys these guys are 1/2 1/2 1/2
they also induce this optimal flow and
they are still a cup ouple Ibrahim's so
no one wants so no link operator wants
to deviate from this you can actually
prove this but why do I want that and
not these so this is even better
they still induce an optimal flow here
you still induce an optimal flow so the
same flow in this induced and the
payment of the users is only 1 over 3
because only 1/3 of Units travel here so
what the problem is here is that this
guy wants to decrease the toil and
attract more flow so this is not an
equally not it's not a cop equilibrium
so this guy's not it's not really happy
it will decrease the toll to get more
flow but once this happens everything
will break down so basically we want to
find this but we don't know how to find
it so what we do is we find we can find
this we start sorry this object so we
find the best set of tools that are
opted in using undercut by the marginal
tolls okay so this you can find using a
linear program and this object we don't
know how to how to find but what we do
know is that this solution is actually
good in several aspects so first of all
you have price of Anarchy results of the
type ever was talking in the morning if
the latencies belong to certain classes
so let's say latencies are linear
functions then you know that the
solution you get there it's the payments
in these solutions or no the total I
think it's also for the payments doesn't
matter because the rest is a fixed
quantity here so the payments of the of
the travelers is within a factor of 2 so
the number more more than twice what
they would pay in the best possible cop
equilibrium
on the other hand if you have path with
the most K alternations so you have a
path undirected path take this one that
has one what they call one alternation
here so this like if I flip one edge I
would make it a directed path okay so
here I have one alternation so for the
network like this we know that you
cannot get you get at least at an
approximation factor of two in this case
so so in particular if you have this
series parallel graph then you if you
have series paragraphs then this
solution is optimal minimizes payments
maybe I'm making some made some mistake
this morning could be right so this
would be these guys exactly so that very
good question so this is the green
solution okay this is my green solution
right this is a cop equilibrium it and
it's the one of minimum payments that
were I don't know how to find em hmm so
I don't know how to find this but I do
know how to find this and what I know is
that this is not too far from this
that's the message right no no I think
it's so so in particular then for see
this paragraph we are good if you have
like K alternations we are approximately
optimal if we know that the latencies
have some property we are again
approximately optimal now just to wrap
up there are many there are many
extensions and questions possible so
Ramesh was mentioning so how do you
compute this best set of tools we really
don't know how to do it it seems very
hard this is more complicated than just
looking at cuts and
adding or subtracting values in cuts
it's more complicated like that because
you really need to make sure that you do
have the cap equilibrium condition like
that link operators will not deviate
from their current behavior so elastic
demand that's something we can deal with
with like this objective functions that
ever NASA looked at like surplus social
surplus someone asked this already what
happens if you can handle several edges
so many results break down but there are
situations in which many things still go
through so I think it's very interesting
to try to characterize what type of
ownership you can allow it's not
anything if you do anything then you're
again bad but if you allow certain
certain type of ownership then it's then
still that the results hold and well
there are several other directions but I
guess one of my stalling yeah
no existence I guess then you have right
I think it should be fine yeah I don't
know to be honest yeah but I mean
randomized tolling doesn't really sound
yeah that's another very good point yes
we are assuming that but they don't yes
I agree and I think that's something to
be looked at and I think many things
still go through so there are there is
there is a lot of work on on that on
that direction exactly that can be done
yeah that can be done to games exactly
there are two games right so basically
the second game the game of the
travelers I am imposing that they do
something which is the socially optimal
behavior right so this is like an
equilibrium constraint if you want
[Music]
just a quick question so if you put in
estimate your parameters like really
accurately depending on the congestion
yes can go really bad yeah if the
congestion functions are not that steep
then the answer would be no but if they
can believe that you have arbitrary
things then yes
[Applause]